sleep is a non-negotiable biological
state required for the maintenance of
human life
much like how we need water food oxygen
we also need sleep but why what happens
when we sleep what is good sleep health
and what strategies can be employed to
achieve this
well hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where we'll discuss all of
these questions in this week's video why
because it's interesting of course but
also because many reviews came out in
the journal science last week or the
week before on the topic and i thought
i'd share some of the interesting points
from them
now like many in the uk we gained an
extra hour of sleep last week and so it
got me thinking what is the purpose of
sleep
now here's a fun definition of sleep
sleep is a naturally recurring
reversible state of perceptual
disengagement reduced consciousness and
relative immobility the propensity of
which is patterned by homeostatic and
circadian factors
there are two main phases of sleep
earlier non-rapid eye movement
non-rem and rapid eye movement from
sleep
besides the obvious difference between
the two in terms of eye movement
if you look at the electrical patterns
during these different phases you will
see different patterns of activity
this suggests that different events are
occurring in these different phases
traditionally rem sleep is referred to
the periods where we dream and non-rent
sleep is for other events
in these reviews two major events or you
could think of them as purposes of sleep
are further discussed such as memory
consolidation and waste clearance
so let's take a look at each however
before i forget i will just say that
these events are by no means limited to
the non-rem phase it is partly that this
is when they have been most studies but
could also be when these events are the
strongest
so the first one memory
now we had a fun definition of sleep so
here is one of memory formation
the challenging process of selecting
which new experiences will be stored and
integrated into an existing structure of
memories that need to be simultaneously
preserved and modified
this process is also more formally
referred to as memory consolidation
which results in a generation of
long-lasting memory traces
so when we recall the same information
during wakefulness those same memory
traces are activated
an important electrical pattern thought
to be important for memory that's
observed in non-rem sleep our sharp wave
ripple complexes
swr not to be confused with the
southwest railway
they have sharp waves and ripples as you
can see here
and these can be observed in a region of
the brain known as the hippocampus
in mice if you use genetic tools to
silence some of the neurons in this
region of the brain after the mice have
just explored a novel environment it
impaired their spatial memory of the
environment when they were reintroduced
to it
but it's most likely that it isn't just
the hippocampus that's important for
memory
in fact communication between the
hippocampus and the outer region of the
brain the neocortex is also thought to
be important
now our understanding of memory
formation during sleep is still
incomplete and we may never fully
understand it
but by observing the electrical patterns
and from where they come from there
could be therapeutic potential down the
line for transcranial stimulation to
boost oscillations in non-rem sleep to
maybe enhance memory consolidation
a small study showed that this was able
to enhance performance in humans in a
memory retrieval task
but it could be more useful for treating
symptoms of neurodegenerative diseases
now a second purpose that's discussed in
these review articles is the idea that
sleep is important for waste clearance
from the brain
now the fancy term for this whole system
is known as the lymphatic system
and interestingly it's currently thought
that one of the reasons why poor sleep
is associated with increased risk of
alzheimer's disease which is
characterized by increased memory loss
is because the glymphatic system
operates in a sleep dependent fashion to
clear proteins such as amyloid beta and
tau from the brain reducing the chance
of building up and aggregating
and aggregates of these proteins
amylobuta and tau can be seen in
patients with alzheimer's disease
and so there's aggregating evidence for
this too
for example in healthy young adults they
saw increases in amyloid beta in the
brain when sleep was deprived
how exactly the clearance occurs during
sleep still seems uncertain
but the current model is that waste
clearance feared the fluid in the brain
so the interstitial fluids between cells
and the cerebral spinal fluid
is temporally coupled to the slow
neuronal waves at the stage of sleep and
also dilation and constriction of blood
vessels
so as you can see in this figure the
neuronal activity occurs first then
there is a delay before there are
changes in the vasculature and blood
volume and potentially somehow due to
pressure changes and volume changes that
they cause this can then drive a
subsequent flow of the cerebrospinal
fluid
that possibly contains these aggregates
of proteins helping to clear them from
the brain
anyhow it suggests that the fast glitter
function is also important for being
able to maintain healthy and effective
sleep
but this is still an area being heavily
investigated
so how do you know if you're getting
good sleep health
well lack of good quality sleep has been
associated with many health outcomes
such as porofascular health metabolic
health immunologic health mental health
and cognitive health
so what are the characteristics of sleep
health and then what ways can we use to
try to improve sleep health
well one way to study sleep health and
i've said the word health so many times
now i apologize
is to use the six dimensions of sleep
health
the first one of this is regularity and
so this is about keeping a consistent
period and time for from which sleep
occurs
and the regular sleep schedules have
been linked with diseases such as type 2
diabetes
the second dimension is satisfaction
this is a subjective measure of our own
sleep satisfaction and has also been
shown to be a predictive measure of
health outcomes
the third dimension is alertness
not only is this important for public
and self-safety but it also has health
implications
the fourth dimension that can be used is
timing and so this refers to the idea
that a portion of the events that are
coordinated by our circadian rhythms
occur during biological night when we're
sleeping as we've already seen with
memory consolidation and waste clearance
in the brain
and for those who don't know the
circadian rhythm coordinates the
behavioral physiological and metabolic
processes that occur within our bodies
on an around 24-hour scale
number five on the list is efficiency
this is an effective measure for how
long does it take for you to get to
sleep in other words a ratio between the
time spent to sleep versus the time
available to sleep and this is useful to
assess insomnia
and then the final maybe the most
obvious metric is duration of sleep the
general recommendation we often hear is
that we should be getting seven hours of
sleep per night
but no more than nine hours
so there are evidently many ways in
which we can assess our own sleep health
and improvements and the ability to both
better assess our sleep health and maybe
down the line to improve our sleep
health is the development of sleep
health technology
now wild's technological progress has
arguably probably hindered our sleep in
many ways digital media at night
artificial lighting both of which can
delay sleep onset
on the flip side maybe there are ways
that we can now use technology to better
help understand our own sleep and to
better research into this area in
general
so firstly there's wearables or portable
sleep assessment technologies
now i've never done this and i think
that's partly because i'm pretty content
with my sleep at the moment
or maybe i suggested in this article
that one of the downsides to tracking
our sleep using these wearables could
result in my inferred correlation
between my sleep tracker data and
daytime fatigue spiraling into a
perfectionist quest for ideal sleep
which could also lead to
self-misdiagnosis of sleep disorders
otherwise known as auto-somnia
which wouldn't be very good but the
positives from this technology is that
we can all have a better understanding
of what our sleep health looks like and
how much sleep we're getting
but it's important to make sure that the
use of this technology is also balanced
by education of the validity of these
devices to assess how well they're
actually working with our enthusiasm for
collecting and maybe over analyzing the
data
now a second advantage builds on from
this point and that is as these the
fighters become cheaper and more
accurate they could be used to generate
large data sets of sleep in many
patients which could help then lead to
actionable knowledge about real-world
sleep and circadian health and
ultimately help to assess the extent to
which sleep is important to our health
and to evaluate different interventions
that are thought to help modulate sleep
so speaking about modulating sleep
there's also technology that could be
used to help your sleep
now one that you've probably heard of
are these blue blocking glasses
yep people do wear them and there are
also fancy mattresses that can be
adjusted to improve your sleep although
i've actually seen very little evidence
to support that they work but anyway in
terms of the blue blocking classes there
is more evidence for them and hope that
they could be used to treat different
sleep-associated disorders such as
insomnia delayed sleep phase disorder
shift work or jet lag
a recent literature study found that out
of 29 experimental publications
involving the use of these blue blocking
glasses
24 of which focus on sleep there was
substantial evidence that the glasses
were a successful intervention for
reducing sleep onset latency in patients
with sleep disorders
and so the rationale was that they block
blue lights which our eye receptors are
most sensitive to and which are a major
input for circadian regulation now i
don't own these glasses and i don't wear
them but i do tend to keep my laptop
continuously on nighttime modes which
helps to reduce blue light on my screen
a few other tips to improve sleep health
are listed out here
it includes things you probably already
know such as the obvious avoid caffeine
and large meals before bed
try to relax and lower your body
temperature before sleep
and to keep your room dark and cool and
also to get correct sunlight exposure
so more in the morning than the
afternoon and this is a similar
rationale to how blue light is driving
the circadian rhythm as we just saw in
these blue blocking glasses
and so when you think about it actually
a lot of the fixes to ensure good sleep
come down to a better understanding of
our own circadian rhythm and why
disruption could be considered a
hallmark of aging given the importance
of sleep for memory consolidation and
for waste clearance in the brain
now for some of us though we have no
option but to work the night shift
or for caregiving of young or old or due
to noise-like pollution of where we live
but that only emphasizes the importance
of research in this area so that we can
help those who are most vulnerable to
sleep disruption
so i think you probably knew at the
start of the video that sleep was
important
but maybe now you have a better
understanding of why it's important and
some of the emerging technology that may
help us to get more of it
alright now i'm off to bed i'm joking
not quite yet because i need to say
thank you to my patreon supporters and
to thank you for listening
you